hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about gene tack avec the identity that
Jimmy McGill aka Saul Goodman takes on
after fleeing Albuquerque at the end of
Breaking Bad we're introduced to gene in
a series of flash-forwards that open
each season a better call Saul before we
get into that this video will contain
spoilers I'm going to briefly recap the
gene scenes and better call Saul and
talk about what it might mean in
relation to everything else we know
happened in the Breaking Bad universe
beyond the story itself there are a
couple things I find fascinating about
gene one is that we actually meet gene
before we meet Jimmy McGill after five
seasons of better call Saul it's almost
hard to remember what that was like
since we know Jimmy so well at this
point but I do remember watching the
opening scene of the series and just
thinking to myself what was that we meet
who we can deduce is Saul in the future
but then we have to wait until the next
season to get another look at him and
it's a slow drip of information that
never gives away much the other thing
that's fascinating about gene is that he
exists at the end of the Breaking Bad
timeline when exactly the gene scenes
occur in time has been a long debated
question through the first four seasons
there had been hints but never a direct
reference to what day it was on screen
fans were scrutinizing every frame
looking for a clue with nothing
definitive showing up until season five
in that we see him change out the
Nebraska license plate on his car with a
clear view of a 2012 sticker these
stickers are issued annually in relation
to vehicle registration the 12 indicates
that the registration expires in 2012
which means that the gene scenes have to
occur in that year or 2011 since we do
see snow I think there's a good chance
that they occur in the early months of
2012 for reference to other notable
dates
better call Saul begins in 2002 Breaking
Bad begins in 2008 and ends in 2010 and
of course El Camino ends in September of
2010 and that marks the end of Walter
White and Jesse pinkman's parts of the
story that makes Jimmy McGill the last
man standing based on interviews with
Bob Odenkirk and showrunner Peter Gould
there will be resolution to the genes
story in better call Saul season six he
will get an ending and that ending will
also be the ending of the Breaking Bad
universe or at the very least it will be
the furthest point in time we visit in
that universe Gould and co creator Vince
Gilligan have both been vocal about
wanting to move into new projects after
better call Saul ends so what happens at
the end of jeans story will mark the end
of this road in my mind that adds extra
weight to finding out how historians
while giving the creator's a vehicle to
tie up any loose ends related to the
larger narrative if they decide they
want to so what do we learn about Jean
and what does it mean for the end of the
story in the first teaser we meet Jean
and learn that he is a manager of
Cinnabon in Omaha Nebraska
that's a callback to his conversation
with Walt under the vacuum repair shop
we get a sense of the fear and paranoia
that he lives with when he thinks that
customers recognized him and see the
immediate relief he experiences when the
man walks past we see he has a roof over
his head something basic not exactly
scraping by but not living a lavish
lifestyle either what's most striking
about his job and where he lives is just
the modesty of it all the more we see
the more we realized that this is a life
Saul Goodman would never have chosen we
see he's nostalgic for the past as he
watches all commercials with watery eyes
and the only hint of color we see
throughout all of the gene scenes is the
reflection of the TV in his glasses as
he remembers his old life there's been
some debate about what gene is hiding
from and we see that he is afraid of the
police on multiple occasions considering
that all the players from the cartel
side of the story are dead except maybe
Lalo I think it's safe to say that Jimmy
remains in hiding to avoid prosecution
for the multitude of crimes he's
connected to as Walter White's lawyer
the third gene installment really drives
this home when he finds himself
interacting with the police and a mall
security guard who are pursuing a
shoplifter he reluctantly gives away the
shoplifters hiding place only to shout
out to
to get a lawyer while he's being
arrested this has such an impact on him
that when he returns to work he passes
out on the floor this leads to a
stressful experience at the emergency
room in a cab ride where he gets spooked
thinking the cab driver who has an
Albuquerque air freshener recognizes him
after that we realized that gene has
been preparing for something like this
as he springs into action leaving town
briefly while monitoring a police
scanner we learned that he has a stash
of diamonds in case of emergency a
Panamanian passport and he's decided to
hold on to ed the disappears phone
number just in case
after the cabdriver returns to confirm
that he knows Saul Goodman from the TV
ads gene reaches his breaking point
he calls edy telling him he needs to be
disappeared again because his cover is
blown only the change is mine before the
call is over he ends the call by saying
I'm going to fix it myself he hangs up
the phone and walks away leaving us with
the cliffhanger of what will become of
Jeanne tacca Bukh before we get into
that I want to tell you about the
sponsor of today's video Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
explore new skills develop existing
interests and get lost in creativity if
you're uncertain about what's next
creative challenges and productive
classes can be a great way to help
structure your time and set up
achievable goals right now I'm working
through the class simple productivity
how to accomplish more what's less by
Greg McEwan I've found this helpful and
thinking about how to prioritize all the
work I want to get done and there's so
many more classes to check out drawing
writing and journaling classes can be a
great way to help manage stress practice
mindfulness and feel connected to one
another Skillshare offers membership
with meaning connect with the support of
fellow creatives and enter a community
of encouragement communication and
inspiration so whether you're looking to
fend off boredom focus on self-care
through creativity or join a similarly
creative community Skillshare is the
place to keep you learning right now
Skillshare is giving away two three
months of premium membership to the
first 1000 people who click the link in
the description box to help you explore
your creativity
after that it's only $10 a month I
recommend checking it out you've got
nothing to lose and now let's get back
into the video for all intents and
purposes what happens to Walter White's
lawyer is the only major remaining
question from Breaking Bad we can expect
to get answers to in its run better call
Saul has introduced three new characters
Kim Lalo and nacho his face are unknown
since they don't appear in the original
series we do expect to get answers to
what happens at the ends of their
stories we know how Jimmy ended up in
Omaha living as Jean but we're missing
the period of four years between the
better call Saul season 5 finale and the
beginning of Breaking Bad we have 13
more episodes to go and have to wonder
how that time will be broken up over the
different timelines it's hard to say but
I think that there will be at least one
whole Jean episode on top of the normal
teaser at the beginning of the season
there's also the possibility that we'll
spend some time that overlaps with the
Breaking Bad story but we'll need
another massive time jump for that to
happen of the characters fates we don't
know Kim seems like the most likely
candidate to return in the Jean timeline
we don't know where she is during
Breaking Bad but the phone call Saul
mentions to Francesca in the
flash-forward at the beginning of
episode 405 almost has to be related to
her this could mean that she's in hiding
or incarcerated or something along those
lines and that they have a plan to make
contact on Jimmy's birthday him being
forced to leave town would track with
why this is the one thing he's trying to
take care of before he leaves the focus
of this video is Jean so I'm going to
stay away from the other unanswered
questions there are several popular
theories for what happens to Jean and
they have changed a bit over time the
first is that he turns himself in to the
police and the series ends with him in
prison Walt died Jesse got a chance at a
new life after making it out and so some
fans think that it would be fitting for
Saul to end up doing time some go as far
as thinking that this wouldn't be so bad
since his people skills are such that he
might thrive in that environment and he
could be of use as a jailhouse lawyer
perhaps this would clear the way for a
reunion with Kim even though their
conversations would likely be happening
through bulletproof
class an alternative ideas that when
he's saying he's going to fix it himself
he goes back to his old ways to pull off
one last epic scam to neutralize Jeff
the cab driver and then continue living
his life as Jean this is possible and
there is the reality that his life as
Jean as its own type of prison for Jimmy
but it all feels a little unsatisfying
to me the final idea that I'll talk
about is that he's reunited with Kim who
he's been separated from through the
Breaking Bad years and there are a lot
of different ways that could go it all
hinges on how they get separated in the
first place which is a road I really
don't want to go down in this video
before they were married I saw a lot of
theories about Kim and Jimmy meeting by
chance in the mall or him tracking her
down there's even ones where she works
at the mall she's been there all along
which I'm not a huge fan of I'm really
not a fan of her being around behind the
scenes during Breaking Bad either
because I don't think it makes sense
when he leaves at the end the general
idea with those though is that it would
be a bittersweet reunion where she'd
moved on and he's left to realize how
the choices he made had driven her away
or you know you get the idea after
season five it begins to feel like there
may be a full-on reunion where they come
back together picking up the pieces
where they left off and then just riding
off into the sunset and to be fair
that's easy to root for especially
knowing what we know after seeing season
five but this is the Breaking Bad
universe and that is a place where
there's consequences for your actions
and so the question were ultimately left
with is something that I heard Peter
Gould talk about which I'll paraphrase
it's the question of justice basically
is there justice in the world we know
that Saul Goodman has done terrible
things he's been involved with terrible
things but we also know that deep down
Jimmy has a good heart so then the
question is what does he deserve does he
get what he deserves
does he get more than he deserves I
really don't know but I can't wait to
see I'm gonna end it there let me know
in the comments what you think about
Jean how you think he fits into the
story what you want to see happen and
how you feel about that being
the end of the Breaking Bad universe
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon